Well this is, I think, possibly the best board game
ever which is quite a bold claim. Many people talk
about this as just the perfect game; it involves
strategy and a little bit of luck as well because
of the role of the dice. It's a actually a game
which- people play together, there's talking all
the time, there's trading going on. Sometimes
games suffer because the person playing that
particular turn is the only person really being
involved and the others are sitting waiting for-
This one involves everyone. This is called the
Settlers of Catan. It was created by a German
dentist who also loved board games and it won
the Spiel des Jahres which is kind of Nobel Prize of
um gaming in Germany. It's the sort of game which
gets a mathematician immediately excited because
just look at the layout of this board. It's um
hexagons not squares, and hexagons are just such
a beautiful shape and the tessellation of the
plane using hexagon so as soon as I saw this
game I I was getting very excited. But you'll
see there are also numbers on here, so let me tell
you a little bit about how you play the game. So
you'll see there are different sorts of squares;
there's woodland here and woodland will generate a
different resource of logs. The mine hexagons give
you ore; the pasture hexagons allow you to graze
sheep; the fields then we can grow some wheat; and
then in the hills you can dig out stuff to make
bricks. And each of these will allow you to build
different things. Now how do you get these? Well if
you own a property and it's on say the corner of
these hexagons; we're going to see which of these
is going to generate some resources in this turn,
and I'm going to throw some dice and I've got 10.
So those areas of land which have the number 10
on them will be generating - uh in this case 10
is generating a sheep, so this will generate a
sheep for anybody who's got a property on the the
corner of this land. But unfortunately I I've not
generated anything because I wanted a 5, 4
and 11. So if I'd been here I would have got some
sheep resources. Interestingly, what's the chance
of getting - for example if I'm here - of getting a
12? Unfortunately there's only one way to get a
12 with two dice which is a 6 and a 6. And
this is what this little dot at the bottom here
is telling me, that this is actually quite a hard
thing to generate resources from. So is it a good
idea to put your property here? Because there's
only one chance. Well look at 6 for example, this
has got five dots underneath it - why? Because well
to get a 6 how many different ways can I get
a 6? There are five because I can get a 5
and a 1, or a 4 and a 2, or 3 and
a 3, 2 and a 4, or a 1 and a 5. So
there are five different ways to get a 6; four
different ways to get a a 5. So these little
dots actually help you to do the probability in
this game, because um let's see. You know the if I
put a property here I've got 1 + 5, 6 plus another
4, that's 10 kind of different ways the role of
the dice can generate things for me here. Um let's
choose somewhere else and just calculate uh; let's let
let's go here. That w as 10, so here we got 3 + 2
+ 4 - that's only 9. So this is a less strategic
place to put your property because only 9
out of the 36 different things are going to
generate resources. So this is what you need to
do when you're playing Catan. So a little bit
of mathematical strategy here will help you to
choose which corners to go on. Because you want
to add up those dots cos that's telling you um
the probability, you're going to add up those
probabilities that you're going to generate some
resources if you put your property there. This
is why a little bit of mathematics can help youto play this game.
- (Brady: There must be more to it than)
(just who can crunch the numbers the best though
to win this game or?)
- Well there's actually a lot
of psychology involved, because once you've
got resources you might have found you've just
generated a lot of sheep, and what are you going
to do with all these sheep? And you need to start
trading. So that's actually why this game is so
beautiful because it involves a lot of conversations
and "I'll give- I've got loads of sheep but I
want some some some logs, will you trade me?"
And there's a little- and that's not determined by
the game, that's determined by how much you need
something and how much you can see your opponent
needs things.
- Oh do you have any clay? Will you trade
a rock for a clay?
- But let me talk about another
mathematical aspect of the game which I think is
rather beautiful. It's not about strategy whilst
playing the game, but it's about how you set the
game up. Because if you notice this is a lot of
hexagons placed down on the board. And I place
it down in a particular way, we've got the mines uh
placed here, there are three mines here. But the
beauty of this game is each time you set it up you
can lay the hexagons down in a new way each time.
(Cos these are like- these are modular)
- They are! So you know we could have set this up such that uh
this was uh swapped over. And so actually perhaps
there's a lot of woodland, you know we could have
a a whole great big forest here. So the numbers
actually must stay the same, although they can
actually rotate. So I was intrigued about, you
know, well how many different games are in this
box? You know Monopoly you only get one board so
there's only one game but there are so many games
inside this box because of the permutations you
can do. So um I thought it might be fun with your
Numberphile audience just to calculate how many
different boards there- there can be.
- (The hexagons)
(can go- can they go anywhere? Is there any rules
or restrictions?)
- No there are none at all so-
(It sounds like it would be quite easy then)
- It isquite easy but there's a little bit of subtlety
here because obviously- so you'd say okay, how many
squares are there?
- (Well hexagons, how many-)
Oh my gosh yes, there's like-
- (How many hex-)
- Howmany hexagons are there?
- (Okay: 3, 7, what's)
(that 12, 16 - is that 19?)
- 19 and these are called
hex numbers. So hex numbers go 1, 7, 19 and it's
the number of hexagons you need. You know we
made- there are expansion of Catan, this is the
basic version. Little challenge for Numberphile
viewers: uh what's the formula for you know
like the a Catan board with n layers? There's a
way you can generate these hex numbers. The hex
number for this board is 19. There are actually
19 factorial different ways can lay the hexagons
down. So, you know, I can- let's- we can start in the
middle; there are 19 hexagons, I can put the first
one down there then we we go around in a circle
and then do this circle. So at first it looks
like there are 19 factorial different games you
can play in the Settlers of Catan. But you have
to remember some of these hexagons are actually
the same because I've got three different hexagons
which are mines. So actually I could have put these
down like this and the board hasn't really changed.
It means that these three mines can be permuted
around and I don't really get a new game. So I
need to divide that 19 factorial by 3 factorial
for the mines. Now the other resources, there are
I think 4 um - oh no let's see, look, there are
only 3 of the hills so that's another divide
by 3 factorial. The other ones are all 4
so there are 3 of those, so I need divide by
3 factorial, 3 factorial, 4 factorial, 4
factorial, 4 factorial. And that will give me
uh the total number of- so let's just add that
up, make sure that uh 4 + 4 + 4 -- 12, plus 3,
15 + 3, 18 and you get- but there are 19. And that's
because there's actually a little desert. If you
generate the number 7, you'll see that 7
isn't anywhere here, it's the most common throw of
the dice. And so that has a different function in
the game. So that's given us our 19 hexagons, 19
factorial divided by 3 factorial squared, divided by
4 factorial cubed. It's the total number of ways
I can lay these hexagons down.
- (What number doesthat give us?)
- It gives us uh a very large number
and I think I remember when I calculated it, if
we played a different game each night ever since
the dinosaurs were around we'd still be playing
on different boards. So so that's quite a lot of-
in fact let's let's look it up cos I did actually
calculate it in my new book about games! Um here we
go, my little hexagons. There are actually 244
billion, 432 million, 188 thousand different boards in
that game. Actually there is a little few more
subtleties to this um which you have to take
into account. So um the way these numbers can be
laid on the board, actually it's a fixed way but
they can be rotated in six different ways. So
actually you- you have to multiply up by
another 6. Um and then there's another subtlety
which I haven't talked about which are little
ports that you can land in and they do different
things in the game which also determine another
few factors more of the way that you can play
this game. So there are a lot of games contained
in this one single box.
(Is Catan a game wherepeople debate strategy or?)
- Yeah there's a lot of
debate of strategy about where to place um your
properties as you're settling Catan. And so
that's important to look at these numbers because
you want to go places where you're more likely to
be generating resources because of where you've
placed your uh properties. Um there's also uh
another part of the game which is laying roads;
so you're interested in in making the longest
road and that wins you things in the game. And so
again there's an interesting strategy about um how
am I actually going to lay roads through this
tessellation of hexagons? Um what's the longest
road that's possible um in the settlers of Catan?
That's another nice little mathematical challenge.
(Professor, you're a mathematician, and you like
playing games. Do you often play games with other mathematicians?)
Uh yes because very often people
who are not mathematicians get wise to the fact
that this guy seems to have some tricks up his
sleeve and I often find my children stop playing
games where I have a kind of an advantage because
of my mathematical uh goggles. But uh yeah there's
I mean a lot of mathematicians love playing games.
But I think you'll find that many mathematicians
do not like a game which involves any element of
chance. They like it to be pure strategy, so games
like chess or the the game of Go, Chinese game
of Go. Intriguingly though, chess originally came
from India and it actually involved dice. So the
early versions of chess, you would throw a dice in
order to determine which piece you were allowed
to move. And then the use of dice and gambling
was banned in India and people had to take these
dice away and then they thought, actually we
can just play this as a pure strategy game. So I
think people uh might be surprised to learn - one
of the things I learned when writing this book
about games - is that um actually dice were part
of chess originally.
- (Have you ever played a game
of chess using that rule? That'd be amazing)
Yeah I think it's um a bit rubbish actually, because you
know you're really wanting to move your knight and
the the role of the dice is uh forcing you to move
the rook. And um there's another interesting thing
I discovered about chess, which is it wasn't
a 2-player game originally but 4-player
game. And actually you can see that um in the game that
survived, because your army consists of two knights,
two bishops, two rooks and the point is that you
actually captured one of the other players armies
and it became part of your your army and that's
why you see these doubling up of pieces in thegame.
(Do you know what I would love to know? Cos
I'm not good at chess. I know the rules but)
(I'm not- If I played against Magnus Carlsen a game
of chess, where I could move any piece and he could)
(only move pieces determined by dice, who would
win the game?)
- I think it's a really interesting
experiment, yeah we should set that up and just see
you know how much of a handicap is it to be forced
to play certain pieces in the game. I think for me
as well, chess suffers a little bit because anyone
who knows their openings um actually has such
a big advantage. So um they can get to a place
in the game, if you don't know your openings you're
already weak after 11 moves. Which is why sometimes
I think if you're playing somebody who's really
good at chess it's probably good to start in mid
game and start from both armies being in a strong
position because of a Sicilian Defense for example.
If you're a fan of games, check out today's
episode sponsor Jane Street. They love games.
So much in fact they've even invented one, more
about that in a sec. Jane Street's a quantitative
trading firm with offices all around the world,
you can see there. Now obviously they're passionate
about solving high stakes, complex problems - it's
part of their business. They're experts at machine
learning, mathematics, statistics - all that kind of
stuff. And that problem solving passion extends to
puzzles and games. The team at Jan Street often
spend free time playing each other at chess and
go and, yes, even Catan! And they created this card
game called Figgie to simulate elements of markets
and trading. It looks pretty cool, something you
might be into. You can play it online at figgie.com
So why don't you go and have a look at that.
And while you're there check out Jane Street as a
place where you might like to work. As you can see
they've got all sorts of jobs, internships, training
programs available; there's always new stuff coming
up on the site. Check it out janestreet.com or
see the links in the video description. I've
got the link to Jane Street and Figgie down there.
Check out more videos with Marcus du Sautoy.
Youknow he's really into games, in fact he's got
a new book out at the moment called Around
the World in 80 games, I'm also going to link
to that in the video description.
- Interested asa sculptor and yeah, well what about taking this
atomic shape, the tetrahedron, and and seeing
what you can build?
- This was mathematicians
hope that- okay there's some the weird logical
gidillian sentences which who really cares about